And everybody, welcome to another Zoom call.
We're going to jump right into your questions.
Good for everybody to see that you're using the announcements
page.
Remember, the last two weeks, we had a cancel.
It was traveling, but for sure it's still
be able to do the Zoom.
And it did not work.
Let's talk in traffic.
Both times, it's not able to get back.
So I apologize for that.
All right, for the questions that my cheeks
while the recommendation this week,
you put 2,000 milligrams per day for the vitamin C
powder that you need in one scoop, which is 2,200 milligrams
or the part that is vitamin C, which is 1,220 milligrams
vitamin C per scoop, which would eat around 2
scoops per day.
Hold on a second.
Let me look up on what I did on the yours.
So the size.
So your vitamin C powder, 2,000 milligrams per day.
Oh, so what I meant on that is at least 2,000 milligrams
of vitamin C per day.
So if there's only 1,220 milligrams of vitamin C
per scoop, try to get 2 scoops that, sorry.
That's where the 2 scoops are now.
I had H-M-E-T and biotoxid binder on this,
doesn't matter which one, don't, attest to them
because it sounded like you may have one.
Onions were attested both, and they both tested fine.
The carboxy tested fine, too.
So I would use up the carboxy first.
The E-T and the biotoxid binder both tested the same.
So whichever one you have, you could use.
So my tumor markers were never out of range,
even when I had tumors.
Before, double mastectomy was done in September 2023.
Recently, I've had an increase.
That outside normal, but moving in the wrong direction.
Since 2024, September 24, taking Dr. Sheet,
are meant to stop reoccurreds and metastasis.
Could these have caused the tumor markers to fluctuate,
like chemo does sometimes?
I don't always get to the lab company.
Same lab company, unfortunately,
and here's the comparison of the last ones that you gave us.
No, I don't think that the products would cause
the tumor markers to fluctuate, like chemo does.
So chemo causes tumor markers to fluctuate,
typically because it's killing cancer cells
through the process of cell lysis versus apoptosis.
And you'll, through cell lysis,
you are liberating everything inside the cell,
including what you're called endotoxins.
And you are causing more issues,
as far as spilling two-arker proteins possibly.
So no, I don't think Dr. Sheet's products
would change the tumor marker test.
You just did a cheek swap for me this week
and I sent you the entire comparison grid.
I don't know if you referenced it before you began.
The only thing's different
is that I have a Dr. Sheet supplements
and my diet is off for a couple of months.
I just don't know what to do next about this, if anything.
But you do a cheek swap and there are differences
going on.
Do you just check the previous supplements
or do you check to see if I need anything?
So I check to see if you need other things too.
So I don't remember if any additions came up
on you, but it's not uncommon that we have an addition
because I'm checking other things.
That may have tested since the beginning
because something may have changed.
So no, there was a daily additions on you
just nothing else tested for that.
So you don't need to worry about adding anything.
Would you recommend testosterone therapy
for recovering cancer patients?
I'm 72 and doing well post bladder cancer operation
one year, but my energy level has never returned.
I have her testosterone can be,
have an accelerated effect on cancer cells.
So I, you know, a lot of times when people ask
about testosterone therapy,
they're actually talking about
handers of deprivation therapy
with a prostate cancer.
But that's not, I'm very sure that's what you're asking.
You're asking about testosterone replacement therapy,
which would be bioidentical, horrible replacement therapy,
using testosterone.
Is that bad to do for cancer patients
or male cancer patients?
With bladder cancer, I would say,
no, it's, I wouldn't say it's bad to you.
So I would recommend, so I pull it up here real quick.
There's a product that we have just started
carried private label product called Stamina.
It is marketed outside of our private label.
It's marketed as a product to increase testosterone levels.
And it's, it's because of what the ingredients are.
So it has this long a folia extract,
or coma long a folia extract,
which is shown to increase testosterone levels.
But the reason why we private label in this stamina
is that that ingredient is not just
for increasing testosterone levels.
It's for basically increasing exactly
what we called it, stamina in males and females,
not just males.
So it doesn't basically increase testosterone.
It gives you that same type of boost though.
It also has chia chilegit in it as well,
which is so good for not, not just,
it's so good for balancing hormones.
It's really an adaptogen as what it is.
Plus it is also a, he later, it's just a great product.
I personally started taking this product
that I was so happy with it that I thought
we got a private label this.
Now we haven't done any, haven't done any videos
on under blog post, under anything yet.
So we just got this in.
But I would as opposed to going with a testosterone
bioidentical hormone replacement,
I would use this product because it has
so many other benefits.
There's data out there by taking,
taking chilegit with, by itself,
it's got 500 milligrams of that unit
per two capsules of the product.
There's data that is amazing on that product.
So I would use this and not do testosterone replacement.
Personally, I am trained in bioidentical hormone replacement.
That was part of my functional medicine training
through A4M years ago.
But never did it,
partly because of my licensure issues.
I can't legally do that.
But I never wanted to do it,
because even though that was the center point of my training,
I just, there's such a small percentage of people
that I think that would benefit from that
compared to that it could hurt them
if they did have a unknown cancer.
So in that sense, the truth is just because,
okay, in one sense, okay, I don't have prostate cancer.
I had bladder cancer.
Well, there's no telling that a person may have
a small secondary prostate cancer
growing, increasing testosterone levels
with that be harmful.
It could be in another sense.
Is there any harm in doing bioidentical hormone therapy
when you don't have any hormone-related cancer?
I'm not completely against it.
It's just having that balance.
I understand the person has that major issues,
especially in female,
it's having major issues trying to get their hormones balanced.
If you're using progesterone or using estrogen
or using testosterone can be extremely helpful.
So I'm not saying there's not cases
that could be greatly benefited from it.
But I don't know, I would try a product like this before that.
Question came in from the chat.
Thank you for answering my questions.
Should I be concerned about the CBA and the CAA2729 levels?
It's achieved up slowly.
Well, should you be concerned about it?
No, should you keep an eye on it?
Yeah, you should.
Let's keep an eye on it.
Let's do that every three months or so
and make sure that things are staying in balance,
make sure that there isn't something else
that we need to add or do or change.
So, yes, I just returned from a doctor's appointment
to address changes that need to be made in my thyroid
and cholesterol medications.
I blood pressure really started at 199 over 71.
The doctor took it again later and it was 204 over 76.
I have had blood pressure issues for years
but never this high and currently taking bergamut
and ubiquital on a daily basis
in order to address these issues.
This doctor tells me that I'm at a very high risk
of heart attack or stroke.
She is having remodeled my blood pressure
again on Monday, Wednesday, Friday, random times
for four weeks.
She predicts that I will need to be
at a low dose blood pressure medication.
You have another areas of concern
which we have addressed in my recent Zoom call into you
should I be concerned about potential side effects
going on in medication to address these issues
that seem to be getting progressively worse.
Okay, so typically,
there are going to put you on an ACE2 inhibitor
for blood pressure which would be on a citipril
or something like that.
Gotta be careful with blood pressure.
The white coat signal was extremely common.
Could your blood pressure just be high
because of those reasons?
Yes, I think it was wise that you need
a blood pressure cup at home
even though those home blood pressure
cups are extremely inaccurate.
It does give you kind of a range
of what your blood pressure could be running at.
And if it's much more back within normal range,
then you have to think that it's very possible
you're just dealing with white coats at will.
Which means your blood pressure goes up just
because you're nervous
so your blood pressure is very highly responsive to cortisol
and that's not uncommon.
Are there other things to decrease blood pressure
other than the citipril?
Interested study came out
a number of years back
that showed pomegranate juice actually works better
than an ACE2 inhibitor.
A pomegranate juice just the standard
over the counter pome bred pomegranate juice
is what was used.
Now, I know you could probably buy it organic one
and such like that.
I don't know how much pomegranates are sprayed.
I don't know to look up the 30 dozen list on that.
I don't think it is in that list.
But just using four,
I think the study was using four or six ounces
of pomegranate juice a day.
Lowered a person's blood pressure
greater than 20 milligrams in the citipril.
It was crazy study.
So that's something to consider
some natural approaches to lower blood pressure too.
Always when a person has high blood pressure,
when a person has any thing,
you always are asking the question,
why, what's the most common cause
of elevated blood pressure?
It is has to do.
And that's exactly why ACE2 inhibitors work.
The common, so ACE2 inhibitors block the ACE2 receptor
sites on your smooth muscle cells
that are right underneath the endothelial cells
of that surround that make up your blood vessels.
So the smooth muscle cells have the ACE2 inhibitor,
ACE2 receptor,
and what happens with that ACE2 receptor
is fired that it causes contraction of the smooth muscles
and will effectively increase your blood pressure.
Others, your blood pressure should go up
at times of stress and should be down
at times of calmness.
That's normal.
Your blood pressure needs to go up at times of stress
because it needs to shut blood to your extremities
so that you can run away from a predator or something.
But then in a calming time,
your parasympathetics should be calming those receptor sites
and you should have a normal blood pressure.
Now, the problem is that the most common causes
of blood pressure are heavy metal toxicity,
bacterial infection,
and probably the most common bacterial infection
is H. Pylori.
These attach to the ACE2 receptor
and fire it causing an increased blood pressure
and there's other mechanisms of action
in the covalent with the bacterial infection like that.
That's why I'm so into H. Pylori,
3D-H, Pylori, and dealing with H. Pylori.
So you want to look at that as a possibility too.
So this is the thing is you look at blood pressure issues,
common treatment for it also is NAD
and nitric oxide, things like that,
which you have to be careful with those
because that also increases epithelial growth factor
of a cancer.
So a person has cancer.
You have to be careful with some of the natural approaches
or cardiac issues and the ethereal issues.
I blood pressure issues do a treat them kind of opposite
so you have to be careful with some of the natural approaches
to those things.
So, yeah, so I know this question I think was posted
that I shouldn't have answered it a week ago I think
so you still have any questions.
Make sure you get ahold of them.
Next question, my 44-year-old brother has been dealing
with dermatographia, skin writing, and itchy all over for two years.
The itchy is mainly torso back and head.
Sometimes his legs, never palms are feet,
he's clearly taken over the counter,
bent and gladiatories,
we take it every three days.
So really, this is really not the avenue
to ask questions about your brother
so your brother should really make an appointment
with me and we should go from there.
So, there's just too many things going on.
Dramatic graphias very common with Lyme disease,
chronic Lyme disease.
That's your first thing you get to get with this.
But it's because it's so common in the Lyme community
that that is an issue.
But the truth is any inflammation,
any inflammatory skin disorder,
which can be a host of different antibodies
that you can develop to your muscles and your skin
can be a cause of this.
So doing antibody testing would be the way to go with this.
I watched your video on ENOX2 protein.
It seemed like that is an early marker of cancer.
Is there a test you can use to monitor this protein?
If so, it makes sense to use to track the progress
and toward revision.
There used to be a test to mark this.
That's one of the reasons why I created that video.
There used to be a test
and there was supposed to be another test coming out
that you could test for that.
It just got to be too expensive
and the lab did not proceed with the further creation
of that test.
It got to be a couple thousand dollars to run the test,
so they scrapped it.
It was just a high level, high degree of education
that would have to take place in functional medicine community
to get doctors to order that test,
especially at that price.
We just could not continue with business.
So unfortunately, there's not a present time test to mark
the monitor ENOX2 expression.
So that's what the test measured
is, the expression of the ENOX2 protein.
Because the ENOX2 protein blocks apoptosis.
So, it stimulates glycolysis.
So, increased levels of ENOX2 protein.
With somebody as a minister, it's not a good thing.
There is ways to,
think I talked about that video.
There is ways to naturally block this protein.
And that's actually the mechanism action of cayenne pepper.
So cayenne pepper is such a good product for cardiovascular,
that's good for both cardiovascular and for cancer.
So, that way it sends a couple of minutes ago
that there's a lot of products that are contradictive
in cancer that you would use for cardiovascular and vice versa.
The cayenne pepper is one that's good across the board.
That's why you should be eating hot sauce, I like food.
Now I say that because I grow a lot of cayenne peppers
in our garden and make a lot of hot sauce.
So, cayenne pepper is great for that.
So, it's something you could do to treat without even knowing.
You're in like this.
My short for the blog, I've been told, there's a chat,
I've been told to take Sam E for liberty toxication,
but it has folate in it that has mental tetrahedral folate
and vitamin B12 as mental clavolomy.
I remember reading in your book,
not to take anything that has methylated,
what is your opinion?
Well, I'm not a big fan of taking Sam E anyhow,
because Sam E is not necessarily horrible,
but it doesn't work on a negative feedback wheel
to block the anxiety pathway.
So personally, I don't know that I ever carried Sam E
and you, Sam E for my patients.
Now, Sam E is used to be, I don't know how,
because I've kind of been out of that realm
for a number of years,
Sam E used to use a lot with people with mood disorders.
Now, the issue with it is sometimes it make people worse.
And the reason why it would make people worse is
because just that, most Sam E products also contain
a lot of methyl groups.
And if you take too many methyl groups
and you didn't take a deep enough dive on your genetics
and you have defects in your biopter and pathway,
especially the pathway that makes serotonin.
You can actually, you don't clear serotonin very well
and too many methyl groups will push that pathway
and you'll have excess serotonin.
Now, most people think that serotonin
is your happy neurotransmitter
and it makes you happy that people with two little serotonin
have depression, head serotonin uptake inhibitors,
which block the uptake of serotonin,
leading block the clearance of serotonin
from receptor sites.
But the truth is, it's the imbalance that's the issue.
So if you have excess serotonin,
then you can end up having, you know,
anger issues, rage issues,
all sorts of other mood disorders.
So even if a person does not have cancer,
so let's say a person does not have cancer,
contact us suddenly.
They want help with their genetics
and so we're trying to assist them with their genetics.
You want to look at all the different pathways
to make sure that you're not using a supplement
and pushing a pathway that you don't want to push
because of deep X.
That is probably the most common issue
with non-cancer patients that taking excess methyl groups.
And I would say the most common errors
that naturopaths or caripretters
make not understanding the full genetic picture.
So now for a cancer patient,
it's a whole different follow-ups.
Access methyl groups in a cancer patient
will actually silence tumor suppressor genes.
So you have genes inside each cell
that if the cell goes into rapid replication,
your tumor suppressor system kicks on.
Now you've heard of some of these genes before,
T53 gene, that's the most research tumor suppressor gene,
but probably the most spoken about is the bronca genes.
So bronca genes are tumor suppressor genes.
Now there's a whole bunch of tumor suppressor genes,
Keras genes, P10 genes,
and a whole bunch of different tumor suppressor systems.
God put all those inside yourself.
Now what silences those is methyl groups.
If you have excess methyl groups inside the cell,
you'll basically turn those genes off.
So you will block, you'll, in effect, block
the what's called an intrinsic meaning inside the cell,
the intrinsic apoptotic pathway.
That's the pathway inside the cell
that causes a stimulation of cell destruction.
So if the cell is gone bad,
whether it's in rapid replication, like a cancer cell,
or it's become toxic, that cell needs to die,
or it's become infected, that cell needs to die.
Now your tumor suppressor gene will kick on
and cause an intrinsic apoptotic capsaic pathway.
Stimulates this capsaic pathway.
Think I have some videos on it somewhere
that stimulates cell destruction.
So the cell will kill itself and you won't get cancer,
or you will help fight cancer.
So certainly when a person has cancer,
you don't want excess methyl groups.
Certainly you don't want excess methyl groups ever.
And it has been, you know, an error I think
in the naturopathic slash nutritional slash chiropractic
community, to give people too many methyl groups.
And for this very reason that it could actually lead
to a cancer growth that would normally be destroyed
through the intrinsic apoptotic pathway.
The size of fact that it could lead to excess bioptera
issues, expushing the bioptera pathway
and causing mood disorders.
And there's a whole bunch of things.
I mean, I just, so long, long way too long answer
to your question.
You were told to take Sammy for liver detoxification.
I wouldn't do that.
Sammy, and methyl,
methylation is a small piece of the liver detoxification pathway
gets your methyl groups naturally through eating
flow rate rich nutrients in your food.
And that's why I tell people, okay, you're not ever
going to be deficient to folate.
You're not going to be deficient in methyl groups.
You're not going to have a, you're not going to have a
hypo methylation.
Even if you have C677MTHFR or C1298MTHFR defects,
you're not going to have hypo methylation
if you're eating greens.
So most of our cancer patients are eating salads,
they're eating greens.
The people that end up with a hypo methylation issue
are people that have double allele defects at C777,
especially that or double allele defect at C1298.
And they are like, they don't eat any vegetables, okay?
So they're the people that, you know, maybe kids,
maybe need some extra methyl groups.
So it's, I personally would take that.
There's other ways to help with liver detoxification
and I would not use that product.
Hope that helps.
Okay, well, we will call it a night.
Thanks for your questions.
And God bless everybody.
We're supposed to have a snow storm up here tomorrow,
so we'll see what happens.
We prayed for us, we're praying for you.
Love all of you.
Have a great night. Bye-bye.